جنود من الناتو مصابون كسور وحروق وجروح
خطره في مواجهات مع محتجين صرب شماليه
كوسوفو
مشاهد اعتبرت قياده حلف شمال الاطلسي انه
لا يمكن التساهل معها فاعلنت ارسال 700
جندي اضافي لتعزيز قواتها
جنود الناتو ابطال في عيون البان كوسوفو
فلولا النيتو لكانت كوسوفو قد انتهت لذلك
هذه اخبار ساره لكن الكوسوفيين لديهم
ايمان بشرطه بلدهم والمشكله في الواقع
بشان البلديات الاربع هي مع شرطه كوسوفو
لان وجودها هناك يثبت سياده الدوله
وسع جنود القوه الدوليه المعروفه نطاق
السياج الامني في محيط مقر البلديات
المتنازع عليها لكن الود بين الناتو
وحكومه كوسوفو ليس في احسن مستوياته فقد
الغى الحلف بقرار امريكي مشاركه برشتين في
مناورات
ردا على التصعيد الاخير
هذه المشكله بسبب سياسات الماضي والقضيه
كان يجب ان تحل منذ وقت طويل كل العالم
يعرف صربيا نحن نامل بعون الله ثم حلفائنا
ان تتحسن الظروف
صربيا غير راضيه عن هذه القوات تقول انها
ساعدت شرطه كوسوفو على احتلال شمال
الاقليم وتجاوزت نطاق واجباتها
كل العالم يكرهنا وخاصه الالبان يريدون
قتلنا جميعا امريكا تحدث الفوضى هنا ونحن
سنخسر ابنائنا الى اين يريدوننا ان نذهب
نحن هنا منذ الاف السنين هذه كلها صربيا
اكد ان قواته ستظل نزيهه ومحايده تحفظ امن
الجميع بعيدا عما وصفها بالروايات الكاذبه
للطرفين
تزيد عدد هؤلاء الجنود للمره الاولى منذ
نحو بعد ان اعطت السنوات القليله الماضيه
احساسا زائفا في نظر كثيرين بتراجع
التوترات زياده في الاعداد يريد الحلف ان
تبعث برسائل طمانه الى الداخل ولكن فيها
تاكيد منه ايضا وفق مراقبينا بان الناتو
سيبقى عامل الاستقرار الاول في البلقاء
محمد المدهون الجزيره من بلده زفيتشان
شماليه كوسوفو